no no it's okay come on it's your
birthday they sing they act they pour
their heart and souls out in the
voiceover booth we've got 30 celebrity
actors behind the voices of some of our
favorite characters and this list
includes countless award winners we're
talking grammys to oscars let's have a
listen
how cute
number one
he's getting ready to go to infinity and
beyond her sevens might not be captain
america anymore but that doesn't mean he
isn't going to be some kind of hero our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking no one
you were narrating again i was not the
marvel actor is the voice behind the one
and only legendary buzz lightyear in
light year and this dialogue is good to
infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
i love that the last time evans had done
voiceover was back in 2008 for the
series robot chicken number two
spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider can including voice acting our
friendly neighborhood spider-man worked
opposite his marvel co-star chris pratt
when he gave voice to the blue elf ian
lightfoot in onward okay i gotta go bye
mom plenty of fun was had between these
actors and their recording sessions
together this is so fun tom it is fun
number three
is there anything she can't do she's got
fierce style spot on comedy and voice
acting chops so good that we never would
have known she was the person behind eep
in the croods high fire
it's different from what she's done
before but her talent is still there
number four
this guy has voiced quite the array of
characters onward saw him pairing up
with tom holland bringing all that older
bro wisdom no from your heart's fire
and among his many talents giving voice
to lego definitely stands out
number five
or we could call her margot rabbit yeah
it's actually a bit confusing we know
robbie mainly for her on-screen roles
but she dug into her animal vibes
voicing the sweet flopsy rabbit in the
peter rabbit films everything's upside
down who knew there could be so much
adventure for a bunny you went into his
garden number six
it's time for the lola bunny jam zendaya
got to voice one of the coolest animated
characters there is lola bunny in the
one and only space jam a new legacy i've
made my family proud we have no doubt
she does that every day anyway
number seven
she can sing act and moo
moo
we weren't kidding all rihanna's moving
skills came in handy when she was
playing tip in the movie home just let's
do it knock knock who is there the
interrupting cow she evidently loved her
time in that recording booth yes yes
number eight
we've got another triple threat coming
up
in your face space rock j-lo voiced the
sly saber-tooth shira an ice age
collision course wait this this half a
snack is a dinosaur whisperer just like
her songs every note was on point it's a
very scary story
you think you can handle it the actress
also worked with rihanna in home where
she played lucy tucci oh timmy my
beautiful girl who else wants to hear
more characters voiced by this
firecracker number nine
who doesn't want to hear a smooth
velvety voice in a movie
bruno mars voice got to reach the masses
in a way we'd never heard before when he
played the smooth talking roberto in rio
2. he's just a swab in the animation
world as in the real world this old nest
is just something i put together last
minute
with my own two wings of course
number 10
wonder woman wears many faces including
animated ones the superhero actress got
to be the voice of shank in the film
ralph breaks the internet and we honor
yours butcher boy showing just how
skilled this wonder woman is
number eleven
it's not often jessie j steps into the
voiceover booth but when she does it's
good well hello handsome jessie j's
voice reaches new heights when she acts
her portrayal of brook and ice age
collision course gave us one more reason
to fan girl over this incredible singer
number 12.
is there a movie he isn't in ryan
reynolds's voice and face are everywhere
please welcome the always entertaining
the one and only will ferrell
but did you know he was the one who
portrayed guy in the croods i call them
shoes
number
13. maleficent is just one of the fierce
roles on her resume kung fu panda
brought us the one and only tigress why
are you really out here angelina brought
heart and sass through her voice
translating to a powerful and memorable
on-screen performance
this tiger slayed
number 14
it wasn't game of thrones but there were
still dragons involved the got alum lent
his voice acting talents to the how to
train your dragon franchise as the
expert dragon hunter i know this
handiwork griml the grizzly famous back
from where i'm from an appropriate role
if there ever was one
number 15.
are the smurfs california girls that
means you're just like me this
california girl went from singing in the
booth to acting when she played
smurfette in the smurfs film
number 16.
belting and ripping between takes was
only fitting ariana spent more time
talking in the booth than usual when she
was recording her lines as laura in the
2013 film underdogs you think there's
nothing in the world you can't own her
vocal power totally translates to acting
number
black widow is just one of the fierce
characters she's played scar joe
slithered her way into the jungle book
film in 2016 as kah the snake would you
like to see
this actress is an old pro having voiced
the one and only princess mindy in
spongebob squarepants
number 18.
can you feel the love tonight beyonce
could when she was bringing it as nala
and the live-action lion king years
before though she played the part of
queen tara in an animated film called
epic parade
fun
smiling this performer's range is way
wider than we could have imagined but
she is queen bae for a reason
number 19.
you don't want to mess with him even in
an animated film idris elba was playing
large and in charge with his voice
bringing the cape buffalo police chief
bogo to our screens in zootopia you
strike out
you resign with this cheap around
zootopia was safe number 20.
just like elle woods this character was
all pink the fact that reese witherspoon
was playing a pig helped the whole pink
factor we're used to seeing her face on
screen but her vocal performance as
rosita in sing is just as impressive
would you please tell them what a good
singer i am if norman won't we will
number 21
what can he say except you're welcome
for his stellar voice who can forget the
rock's powerhouse performance as maui in
disney's moana hero of men his strength
and size really come through vocally
number 22. you want to build a snowman
portraying anna in the frozen films
might just be one of kristen bell's most
famous roles and with good reason the
actress gives life to the princess with
just her voice i don't think olaf should
get to rearrange and she wasn't afraid
to lean into the sass
number 23
professor trelawny is that you from her
feisty performance in cruella to nanny
mcphee to the heartbreaking and iconic
love actually scene emma thompson plays
fierce women in every genre there is
this was no different when she played
queen eleanor in brave
number 24
she's funny as a person and an animal my
name is daisy and i really gotta talk to
him tiffany haddish didn't hold back
when she performed the voice of daisy
for the secret life of pets franchise
okay you don't listen it's daisy
number 25
she can sing and there's no doubt about
it and tori kelly got to show off those
singing shops and more when she gave it
her all as mina in the movie sing
spoiler alert she did uh
i was falling in love she sang and blew
the roof off the house
number 26
follow the white rabbit comedy he's got
it acting he's got it voice over you
know he's got it the secret life of pets
franchise was made that much funnier
with kevin hart in it as snowball the
white rabbit what's it look like i'm
doing i'm doing superhero stuff
number 27
this gal moved out of waverly place and
into hotel transylvania holy rabies this
looks like a blast and to say she was
excited is an understatement good to
know she can easily go from wizard to
vampire and she's cool with human too
number 28
just keep swimming what tag oh there's a
tag on my fan whoa indeed ellen
degeneres was the voice behind dory in
finding nemo great idea you take me to
find him why didn't i think of that but
years later she stepped back into the
booth to voice the blue hippotang once
more though it had been years since she
first played the role her energy was
still high
number 29
who is that slick talking sly fox sly
fox
dumb bunny yes he's marty bird and ozark
but he was also nick wilde in zootopia
and he was just as boss in both in a
booth or on camera bateman's characters
can hustle
number 30
another wacky character on the list this
time david spade brought his talents to
hotel transylvania as griffin aka the
invisible man he successfully gave voice
to a character that didn't have a body
visible half the time that's no small
feat
these actors are celebrities for a
reason the talents are varied and when
they dive into a new project they bring
their all resulting in memorable
performances across movie genres which
of these voice performances are you most
impressed by